maybe it would make sense for America to
actually LeapFrog places like Europe and
Canada and go for all-out legalization
and we were Nick was sharing this piece
with me earlier uh by the late uh Dan
Baum uh in Harper's magazine called
Legalize It All and um I thought this
could be a way to kick off this
conversation he writes that just about
everybody who thinks seriously about the
end of drug prohibition agrees that
we'll want to discourage consumption I
mean that we can put that aside for a
second but the goal could be
accomplished at least in part under a
system of regulated for-profit stores by
setting limits on advertising and
promotion for Banning the or Banning
them all together by preventing
marketing to children by establishing
minimum distances from schools for
retail outlets by nailing down The rules
about dosage and Purity and by limiting
both the number of stores and their
hours of operation and so bomb here is
basically proposing treat these
hypothetical
all you can buy drug stores the same way
you might treat highly regulated liquor
store does that strike you as a
plausible and good model
well I mean first of all politically I
think it's neither here nor there I just
don't see the support I mean as we point
out before Zach even as the numbers Rose
from marijuana legalization and now in
psychedelics we're not seeing the same
type of change I think the one the
country that comes closest to the open
dinosaur model maybe Switzerland
actually where the numbers have been you
know 35 40 percent in the past but even
there they're accustomed to having a
fairly hyper regulatory system and so
they might and they've had a lot of
success in varying ways with that sort
of system there's a greater cultural
tolerance for it the United States we
don't have the kind of tolerance for
those sorts of models I mean
periodically we had you know
post-prohibition with States having you
know liquor monopolies and things like
that but it's not the kind of thing that
one can see really working in America
where we tend to Veer between moralistic
prohibitionist extremes on the one hand
or like Let It All roll you know like
you know you look at European they want
to legalize gambling they still you know
the casinos are regulated they you know
the the state lottos and all this are
saying in the United States when we go
from Probe legalization you know we
start you know having casinos open 24 7
with all sorts of incentives to you know
keep gambling and stuff and we do start
doing lotto and we're hiring AG
companies Design La ads that
specifically appeal to addictive
personalities I mean so we don't do that
middle ground thing secondly I'll tell
you one of my principal ways of of
thinking about legalization it gives me
pause
is I think about you know what some
people would oftentimes describe as the
three most powerful addictive and
omnipresent drugs in human society and
what are those sugar fat salt sugar fat
salt sugar fat salt right now you look
at what sort of multinational food
producing companies have been able to do
on that front right where they're doing
stuff with brain chemistry and they're
figuring out an exact combinations of
the sensual taste in the mouth and the
texture of the sugar fast all
combinations you know we're junk food
not just because of what they're
producing but has become enormously
popular in all sorts of ways and
appealing and you know it's especially
an issue with poor people but this is
becoming more and more of a universal
phenomenon not just the United States
right and you see that obesity the
consequences obesity the estimate now is
possible that obesity now results in a
greater loss of life and of of you know
dollars lost than just either smoking or
all illicit drugs put together right so
and that's happened quite dramatically
in the last 20 or 30 years so if I begin
to imagine a legal system where
pharmaceutical companies can um you know
do what the food companies have doing
and sort of be coming up with all sorts
of neat drug combinations that
specifically generate some level of
dependence but don't do that much harm
at least in the short term that's my
great fear about what could happen there
when I look at a model for legalization
the one that I think comes closest is
one that actually before you go on there
let me just ask
um if that is your fear would that
actually be a worse situation than we
are in right now given the level of
death that is happening from fentanyl
which is the fact that fentanyl is on
the streets is purely a byproduct of the
black market well it's no that's the
right question Zach how do we compare
these relative risks right in fact you
know 30 years ago I put through the
working group at Princeton
um the Princeton working group on on the
future drug use and alternative drug
prohibition and I published a piece
called thinking seriously about
alternatives to drug Prohibition in the
journal the academic Journal Daedalus 30
years ago which really hashed out all of
these so you can find it online but it's
you know it really hashed out all these
issues how do we balance the competing
values at stake including the question
that you just posed right now the
question is is would that in fact
um you know solve the federal issue
um it might it might do that
um you know you know if if you would ask
me the same question four or five years
ago or maybe four or five years from now
if the fentanyl issue diminishes a lot
would that change the calculation but
Zach the thing I would point out is
there is actually a model that emerged
and was actually enacted into law but
never implemented and about 10 15 years
ago New Zealand had a major problem with
synthetic cannabinoids right and people
were getting in trouble with it stores
were popping up unregulated and what
eventually happened was the two biggest
manufacturers of the synthetic
cannabinoids which was kind of not
legally regulated but not legal they
approached the government and the health
Ministry and they said we have a mutual
interest here we know our products are
relatively safe we've done the testing
but we don't like all these Fly by Night
companies and all these pop-up retail
outlets and so and we have a mutual
interest in getting rid of these so what
they proposed and what New Zealand
Parliament enacted with like 110 to one
vote was a system setting up basically
an FDA like entity that were
pharmaceutical companies or anybody
could submit a drug that they had
created to this new fda-like entity and
if they could establish a substantial
margin of safety the government would
approve it for over-the-counter retail
sale to adults even though it had no
accepted medical use so it's like the
FDA thing without requiring medical use
just showing substantial margin of
safety and the people behind that
including in the government understood
that what they were proposing to do for
synthetic cannabis might well be a model
that could apply more broadly to all
other drugs as well now unfortunately
the law was never implemented for
ridiculous reasons when people caring
about animal rights protested they
didn't want to have drugs being tested
on animals and all things shut down but
the fact is the drug that law is still
on the books you know the United Nations
controlled board and our products
control board which normally freaks out
about any reform didn't really quite
know what to do about it so I think
that's the potential regulatory model
which might make a lot of sense and
remember also it's also about like if
you're going to legalize cocaine are you
going to legalize it only in a kind of
cocaine coca-t version which has cocaine
in it or like you know chewing gums and
and sodas like liquid forms are you
going to legalize the sale of 10 pure
potency powder for snorting are you
going to allow it to be sold in
injectable or smokeable forms
um if you only allow it to be sold in
the less potent forms um would you then
uh you know crack down on people who are
selling it in you know who click you
know turn cocaine that they bought at a
pharmacy or a store into crack would you
then crack down on them for selling it
in the pre-made crack forms so I mean
the organization in the UK transformed
you put up one of their slides before
and their public policy specialist Steve
rolls of rol well yes he was the last of
my 80 interviews on my podcast
psychoactive he's really done some of
the most
um you know Advanced thinking on this
stuff he's I tease him about being sort
of a hyper regulator
um which is true it's you know but he's
actually thinking hard about what
regulatory models might make sense for
what sorts of drugs and they have a new
volume that came out in the last year
about how to legalize stimulus which is
the hardest you know we can figure it
out for cannabis psychedelics maybe even
for opioids but the stimulant drugs are
the ones the cocaine methamphetamine are
the really really tricky challenging
ones
you would agree though that movements
towards with almost no exceptions
movements towards decriminalization and
legalization
are to be preferred over the status quo
or a rollback of that yeah I mean I mean
almost totally I mean I mean the thing
is look what I one of the great
advantages of legalization to the extent
that legalization is synonymous with
legal regulation and that's something
that some old-fashioned Libertarians
recoil at but when you define
legalization as legal regulation right
you know one arguments I typically made
is that people think of prohibition as
the ultimate form of Regulation when in
fact prohibition represents the
abdication of Regulation anything that's
not being effectively prohibited is
basically lies outside and is totally
unregulated controlled by gangsters
criminals you know blah blah blah so
when it means when legalization is
synonymous with legal regulation and
when that legal regulation is pragmatic
not overly heavy-handed not not dumb not
which inevitably regulations become dumb
and backward in some areas but where the
essence of it is constructive and
conforms the local culture well I think
that is almost always
um a step forward right yeah I know you
know underground synthetic drugs being
sold we don't want you know the Lord you
know well you don't want them to be
underground but maybe you want them to
be sold but then the people who sell
them you know if they're acting in in
open daylight they can be you know they
can be found they can be sued they can
be held responsible right you want civil
liability exactly it's one of the great
benefits of a legal regulatory system is
you have civil liability for the harms
that are caused and you know some
synthetic cannabinoids may be perfectly
fine other things but you know the stuff
where people are using now with the
xylazine this other tranquilizer drug
out of Colombia that's being mixed with
fentanyl and beginning you know
commercial you don't want that all that
crap there but I I know what you're
saying and this goes back to you know
the kind of Thomas saws worldview which
is beautiful and Powerful in its
Simplicity but you know I when I say you
know I would like to live in a world
where all drugs are treated like beer
wine and alcohol often from my phone
fellow Libertarians I'll be told that
I'm awful because I'm I'm asking for new
taxes you know and need regulations to
be written and it's kind of like yeah I
guess so but you know you know in the
big picture are you [__] kidding but
my perception is it's a substantial
evolution in the libertarian both
libertarian political libertarian you
know where they no longer say
prohibition and Taxation are the same
thing but there's an understanding and
part of that's political pragmatism you
know that marijuana has been such a
great success and you realize that has
to come and part of this matter that the
way you tax how you tax the levels you
tax make a huge difference you know
California got the taxation system all
messed up there are better and reverse
ways to do this stuff and then
ultimately prohibition represents its
own form of tax and it's a far more
onerous one thanks for watching that
excerpt of a live stream that Zach
weismuller and I did with Ethan nadelman
late of the drug policy Alliance about
legalizing all drugs if you want to
watch another excerpt go here if you
want to watch the full conversation go
here and come back next Thursday at 1 pm
eastern time because every week we've
got a live stream with another great
guest that you're going to be into
thanks for watching